[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to
off-the-record where we talk about water
boom and you might be wondering why I'm
such a sharp-dressed individual such as
my buddy here Steve money master Steve
money master Joe we just created a money
master mastering your money master
program oh that's a program that you can
get right now technically you could have
got a little while ago but you should
probably get it right now it has my
friend Nelson he ran the numbers and he
found out that the program is actually
worth half a million dollars yeah but we
said you know what Nelson [ __ ] you do we
they're gonna [ __ ] charge all you
people yeah what do you nothing why you
so greedy
we were Charlie's nice people so much
money so we lured all the way down to a
simple price of $19.99 right
is this a troll because I don't know if
I really buy what you're saying you
don't want to buy it with something that
were selling what are we buying yeah
what do we buy into Gateway doesn't
matter what you're buying it's a great
deal that's not a fair question okay
sorry I asked
this is real yes a lot of people thought
it was a it was a troll why a lot of
people thought we were joking right they
saw the side they saw the skit they were
like this is funny but the true
believers the money boys and money girls
they actually bought into the program we
people gave you money like real money
yeah we got about a thousand people like
ready to go it seems real so far yeah
and what have they received so far what
have you got - so what kind of questions
are these if I'm a potential buyer I
would like to know what the other day
you know what you don't like money you
drink the kool-aid bro I want to let you
guys know that this is not a purchase
okay there's not just something that you
buy it's this estimate is an investment
and your future in yourself in yourself
in your future but why do you take your
glasses off cause he took a while yeah
we plant we practice it yes we
synchronize this yes perfect yeah it's
an investing you know where I was going
at because you see it right what better
time than now then to build a skill
during quarantine oh I know we're kind
of late cuz quarantines starting to lift
off and all that stuff but hey this is
for all the people that kind of shut
your own [ __ ] down I love it they just
missed out you know to me they just they
you know we're trying to like remind
them like quarantine SHhhh Warren team
you know Warren team yep it's like you
could you could you could porn you could
pour in tea no I want to do wealth and
team oh that's it
oh we should write that oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah what's recorded right oh good
I think you're good hey do you need a
job I'm good okay people keep saying
that it's never a bad time to start but
really what it is is that it all evolved
because everybody was like hey we want
him we want to see you guys do skits and
videos and whatever right so we're like
okay what do you want to learn and
everybody that got the program they were
involved and basically building it so
everyone was like hey we want to learn
about this we want to learn about that
teaches [ __ ] Tetris Patrick sex yep
how do I make a chick come how do I make
a boy come yep can we teach that like
one example no look okay let me tell you
something right now
tell me step one let me give you a
little a little taste okay
here's what a lot of people don't
understand everyone always says the same
[ __ ] in all these self motivational [ __ ]
what do they say all the time it's a
dream big
follow your passion yeah yeah yeah we
say nobody's ever literally accomplished
[ __ ] while they were dreaming yep
everyone does everything while they're
awake yep
so you got a [ __ ] be awake big not
dream big dream a big is [ __ ] slay
this [ __ ] I ever heard it is stupid
because when you're sleeping you're not
even doing you're just
they're like you're dead Nelson have you
ever said oh I just pulled an
all-nighter yeah why did you say that
cuz I was doing stuff yeah oh you had to
get [ __ ] done right my man [ __ ] works
he doesn't sleep
hey hey Nelson have you ever said oh no
I slept all night yes how much [ __ ] did
you get done then I got sleep done yeah
[ __ ] see any change you don't make money
yeah but what we do teach you is how to
make money while you sleep wait you work
while you're awake and you set it up so
then things are making money while you
sleep well I'll simply sleep because he
already made it I thought I'll stay up
all night so I can get [ __ ] done well
nobody if you fall asleep yeah you're
still making money right you could take
a nap take a course to understand this
isn't a complicated step-by-step right
you got to be awake because you want to
walk yourself to the dream not live the
dream through your dream stop talking
about dreams in general start being more
and more awake yep
dad I want to sign up but I really have
to pay half a million no no no no we're
giving you a deal
now since the greedy guy that told us to
charge everybody half a million dollar
wait so how much is it
29:19 well yeah we're even giving any
yes 19 that yeah 19 yeah we would have
said yes to 20 but 1999 sounds good see
see that's that's part of the that's
part of the stream is a great year y2k
yeah yep I don't know man I think people
will really enjoy what they see when
they get it it's a two-week program
every single day you got a beautiful
video between the both of us we created
awesome skits or motivational speeches I
would say yeah and there's very various
topics such as how to look at yourself
in the mirror without throwing up mm-hmm
I know everyone's disgusted so when they
look at themselves in the morning while
they're brushing their teeth they throw
up yup this is how to do that without
throwing up also how to stop jacking off
and start jacking in to life Jack into
life what do you think of that kind of
[ __ ]
how's that for you we got a lot of uh
great deals for you guys and also a lot
of information so please check the link
in the description box below and change
your control man only if they want only
want to change your future okay you're
not interested in changing your future
she doesn't want to change your future
all right glass is coming off glass is
coming off all right money Master Joe I
gotta put them to the side for a second
okay it's real we found a really fun way
to get people to face difficult things
in life but make it in a really really
fun way cool yeah hmm glasses are off
also it's very fun and it sounds [ __ ]
fun that's what's fun about it right is
that we're sending up or sounds fun
that's the fun part we're sending up an
industry yeah that I think deserves a
little bit of everything deserves to be
made part of right is talking about
money is born as fun yep well we talk
about money and we make it fun we talk
about money we talk about relationships
we talk about social skills we talk
about everything because all these
things like 500 people they they put in
a survey and they wanted to know like
things like how do you fall in love how
do you budget right how do you like deal
with like with you know how do you like
pay off your credit cards or whatever
right there's all these different boring
things and the idea of answering those
made us want to fall asleep yeah so we
changed tomorrow so it's like how to
[ __ ] until she can't stop coming yeah
that she starts calling the cops
yeah like [ __ ] like that where it's like
how to save a stripper that's one of our
videos we teach people how to save a
stripper and have her fall in love with
you well how do you save what I mean by
save a sipper like Vegas prop stripping
strippers all need help right every
single strip you know that's not their
glasses on or off still Oh sir strippers
definitely all need help and we don't
look down on what they do and then well
you're sitting lower so you look up
exactly yeah that's exactly yes sir he
got a sneak peak of the program yep
I'm actually in guys yeah he knows guys
they are hired in five minutes ago yeah
hey we start rolling like six more all
right I wanna I wanna I want to go
behind the curtain really quick glasses
come off so imagine if you guys were
like in your 20s right and you know you
got to do adult [ __ ] you know you got to
do some life [ __ ] you got to do some
banking [ __ ] all these things right
information is out there
but it's daunting it's like this [ __ ]
sucks I don't to [ __ ] deal with it
right imagine though if it was fun
information like it's really fun to
learn all this you're gonna try to make
look it's fun formation new it looks
like funding your life that's way better
yeah or infotainment how about that and
fun in fun tainment he's good at this
week we really got to act now he doesn't
want a job I will talk I'll give you a
free program you could take the course
okay would you what would you guys say
like I just want to tell you I want to
make more money okay I'll just learn
about life well you're not gonna learn
how to make money you're gonna learn how
to be a resilient heir
exactly you're gonna learn I'm not
making money by knowing your true wait
can I ask just a question then with the
church resilient air comment are you are
you guys resilient
we're on the way like billionaires right
like future billionaires yeah future is
it's all future disrespecting your
future I'm asking the people's questions
I don't get such a hard interview I
don't know you I don't know people are
gonna be such haters I didn't expect it
from my old friend we knew that though
you did we will we warned people in the
program we said people gonna give me
haters they're gonna see you walking
down the street with the briefcase
looking like all sick and stuff and
they're gonna go for memberships now I'm
only gonna use one of them that's how
much of an honor I am we'll see when you
do it yeah I'm gonna check the [ __ ]
stripe account and see if you actually
made those purchase where do I go to get
it I'm gonna leave the link in the
description box below you guys gotta go
check it out we're uh right here I don't
know what our URL is we're talking to
money boys and money girls we're not
talking to everybody with closed minds
sucks of money men that sounds better
money men money boyfriend you got money
man money mint sauce dough money boys is
so cool but they're white belts they're
not ready yet so they upgrade so you go
from money meant to money boys you
upgrade to money boys no you start as
money boys and girls
we're money masters yeah
money master Jo money master Steve so
money boys money men and then money
masters there's no money men oh that's a
new thing he's created I don't know
about that we don't like the way it
sounds frankly okay my bad because it
sounds more powerful than we are and I
don't like that it doesn't sound like
something that someone will want to call
themselves yeah like I think money boys
I think it'll work yeah I think a lot of
people have a money boy yeah yeah we did
a lot of testing your research on this
got it yeah
what are the girls upgrade to money
girls oh they upgrade into marrying
money masters yeah they can marry
millionaires and money masters that's
the goal so the goal here is we're
creating billionaire boys and trophy
wives I'm pulling back my forceps don't
Wow let me read you all right you're
pulling away I can see it what's not the
whole [ __ ] you did it's not the whole
gender part it's about like a guy can be
a money girl and marry a trophy no they
can't I'll get this all wrong
we're so here to get on the [ __ ] nose
yeah you're losing your job what was the
question
this interviews over no Gio doesn't like
the fact that she can't achieve her
lesbian dreams of being a billionaire
herself okay let me help you understand
this real quick cuz I can sense your
pulling away here's how this works you
agree that the system is largely
male-dominated yes and that chicks have
a tougher time right
no oh [ __ ] I wasn't how do you beat that
that she's going against max she's good
man she is good
I think she's woke she's hurting away
we're just saying that for those people
who think that who agree with this that
it's time to start [ __ ] navigating
that system right yeah marry those rich
dudes get that [ __ ] wealth but get
that paper that way yep so [ __ ] up not
down exactly or stop [ __ ] sideways
yeah don't [ __ ] sideways no [ __ ] up the
ladder not down the ladder once if a guy
comes and he thinks he makes you think
that he's up but he's really down all
the time mm-hmm we're just trying to
prevent the strippers from
in care of the guys don't have cars and
they don't take care of them you know
the strippers always taking care of the
guys always nobody talks about this and
the guys like us are always taking care
of the strippers so the money goes this
way it isn't it isn't stay in the circle
well it's because the strippers really
like us the strippers do like us wait so
that might does glide this because you
take out strippers and then they take
care of you no no we we take care the
strippers and then they take care of
their boyfriends but we but the
strippers think that we're really cool
and that they would leave their
boyfriends for us yeah it's exciting
it's I don't know man it's complicated
it's there's a lot to it you guys gotta
check it out and I think we just don't
know where it the name of that URL is
just yet but it'll be it is our jamali
an academy somewhere but I don't it's a
long lean command and it's real so for
the records this is a yes okay we just
keep going in and out of art you know
okay when the glasses come off the
character you were off the whole time
they were talking I know I forgot maybe
we can Photoshop them on your face
during the video editor please when I'm
when I'm joking around
no I mean when I'm in character don't
give this video to me that sounds like a
lot of work
okay can you give me two person glasses
can I have a pair of sunglasses
yeah yeah you could be a bunny boy now
the editor has to sure whoever's
anything so sorry I think this is this
we're gonna revolutionize the world I
think uh Steve had a great idea too the
next step is we're gonna get a private
plane we're gonna get everybody that are
successful money boys and girls right
they're gonna be able to hang out with
us on this private plane when we get to
Vegas that is a shrimp ever gonna take
off I mean shrimp there's a plate every
shrimp doesn't take off thanks it stays
in the other place I pictured a shrimp a
flying shrimp maybe I should keep my
sons off of that actually I think you in
my mind no but the idea is that everyone
will be on this plane I'll have you
having a sick time with us and just like
us to go just like us
we'll have all kinds of video hoes there
yeah so that people can make connections
video where's the plane going a Las
Vegas Nevada yeah they've come video
we're gonna go to Las Vegas because Las
Vegas we all get into a limousine and
then we drive you to a Convention Center
where you're treated to an eight-hour
time sugar free video pappad for the
beginning of the time here meeting I
said we leave and then we pop back in in
the last 10 minutes to give us give a
[ __ ] amazing speech yo where the
timeshares all over really nice areas at
the Appalachians yep the Blue Ridge
Mountains you've heard of them no the
Blue Ridge Mountains yeah people like
them because oh you know and I think
we're just gonna revolutionize this
whole industry cuz it's full of snakes I
think there's too many snakes in the
self-help what's wrong with snakes
they're pretty bad you don't like that
they don't have legs no I just I mean
it's a figure of speech right there
slithery you ever see how smooth area
snake is yeah you ever want to buy
something from a snake sometimes okay so
what's your guys's point of doing this
is it to help you four to make my dope
to make a [ __ ] ton a month wait yeah
people help us make a [ __ ] ton of money
it's a it's I call it a money circle
jerk it's a money [ __ ] so like we
make a lot of money because they made a
lot of money it's like a pyramid you
know the guy it's like everything is a
pyramid right yeah the leaders are on
top and all of the people are on the
bottom
supporting the leaders at top yeah and
you gotta get Flav to bump yep that is
that is the goal here was of you to
obvious will say you're on top yeah am i
I'm on the bottom
yeah but we flipped the pyramid and I'm
on top oh no no no it works like that
because the triangle is one of the most
sturdiest structures ever known to man
what didn't it was still a triangle
look it's unbreakable look it's try to
kind of fit in the Triangle thats not a
trying new something they over here try
to break it dude bring it
can't break can't break the [ __ ] I'll
see where the triangle grab it it's
between his arms grabbing you can't
break you can break it that's what I'm
talking about that's that's power I
didn't break a clue this is the goal
this is the goal like right here you
might be where my thumb is right but
five years later we expand a triangle
see now you're somewhere up here and
you're a leader yourself the top gets
smaller makes sense to buy and quick yes
thank you
act fast act now act fast act now not a
pyramid scheme
no it's just a Shakespeare me to inspire
heavily heavily come on guys what in
life isn't a pyramid there's a president
vice president and all the people right
here House Congress senators you lose
say that about anything that's what I'm
saying that's what life is a pyramid mom
and dad at the top sometimes only dads
sometimes only mom children at the
bottom life took a lot of inspiration
from pyramids shapes Ronald McDonald in
the McDonald's franchise at the bottom
Hamburg the purple guy yeah
I'm side down tree move man yep Mac
tonight dude Mac tonight yep so that's
that's kind of like how we're running
life you know just human nature wise
everything's a pyramid name another
character in the Chuck E Cheese Band
you [ __ ] can't cuz it's a pyramid yep
Chucky on top you think those bad
members aren't [ __ ] pissed at Chucky
you're goddamn right they are yeah they
all look coked out when they're [ __ ]
dancing that's true sure good guerrilla
guy back it's [ __ ] pissed it he's
actually a great drummer yes you shot
your meeting there for the Money boys we
we should we good our first annual
meeting is gonna be at the Chuck E
Cheese
in Las Vegas as soon as quarantine opens
up who's bringing the kid because I
don't think they let you in tiger oh are
you will tell you're letting in with
them take taken Oh
if not we can run a kid yeah I know
where to get it okay we'll just go to
Hollywood
kids oh yeah yeah cascades all the time
thank you guys for this 20-minute
episode of get money masters is it real
or is it fake every every but every
single question we ask that a perfect
answer for that's you I'm saying wait
Casey I still don't know what the [ __ ]
is going on well that's the point
cuz you weren't listening it really
takes a good listener to become a
successful person in life and you two
are very unsuccessful I just don't think
you guys were are willing to take the
next step in your lives and that's fine
that's your personal preference right
but a lot of people at home or what are
willing to take that next step you are
ready to look at yourself in the mirror
and stop throwing up and you really want
to change yourself and be somebody that
you're not successful go ahead and click
the link below we're gonna make you a
money master and don't just change
yourself rearrange yourself that's
another good one for the [ __ ] books
go for you to write it down
[Music]
[Music]